hi I'm Christopher Hine head instructor
at Aikido of Fresno and this is the true
shintani Aikido youtube channel on this
channel you're going to find lots of new
great videos from us or gearing up right
now to do a whole bunch of new videos
you got some new equipment and so
hopefully we're gonna make everything
look better and sound better and we're
gonna bring you guys a lot of new videos
about Aikido the emphasis of this
channel is in bringing Aikido to the
modern era so understanding where we
came from and what we've been doing an
item with Aikido in the past and
understanding how we're going to move
into the future so we're gonna have lots
of videos on basic fundamental movements
so stuff for the beginners and then of
stuff for advanced practitioners also
looking into live practice and how
you're going to actually use Aikido for
yourself so stay tuned to the channel
hit click and subscribe I'm Christopher
hi thanks for watching
you